a disney worker ruined a proposal
oh really let me see we have a video is
that here yes let me look at this
[Applause]
[Music]
and you know what it is man and i don't
want to say this really and i don't know
this
but a lot of uh uh uh disney is known
it's really a hotbed for um
a lot of gay men
go work day it's their first step out
into
uh a place where they're really i think
you know a lot of it's a mecca for gay
men it's basically the wailing wall
in a lot of ways or it's like um
what's another mecca rally
um
like a popular place people go to
build a bear
no that's that's
no like a popul popular place that
people go to
like a you know a national monument or
something
all right thank you for the help brother
it's um
you know it's like a
uh
disneyland has long been a hotbed for
it's like a it's kind of a uh
homoerotic sort of um
a halfway house
for young gay men i believe have you
ever heard this rally
i have
and there you go
and um
and so i don't want us i don't know what
this is maybe this guy doesn't believe
in
opposite sex marriage or something i
don't know
uh
so i'm not accusing anybody i'm saying
that that could be something
that has occurred
um there could be some opposition to
that in that realm
uh you also
uh maybe they just don't let people get
married there
because if you notice a lot of the
different um
cartoons don't have parents
they want you to believe they all
magically occurred and there wasn't any
sex you know
nobody wants to think of like a wet uh
what's a popular disney character riley
mao
mickey mouse
nobody wants to think of us you know
mickey mouse covered in amniotic and
little you know maybe a couple duties
under him or whatever from a crazy birth
you know from coming down the damn um
you know the uh thunder mountain mom's
thunder mountain so praise god baby
but uh yeah i guess they they're they
the man said no he said you go on out of
here
and come back with a faint come back
with a pretty little
come back with a buddy
or something who knows i don't know but
they're not letting them do it
and uh it's kind of bummer i think if
you you see that in the wedding video
just promotes disneyland but maybe
they'd have people doing it all day so
that could also be an issue
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you